entre 40 et 60 commerces
d'Indre-et-Loire dont un tiers à tour
ont été vandalisés lors des émeutes qui
ont suivi la mort de Naël alors quel
stigmate reste-t-il comment les
commerçants vandalisés se remettent-ils
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de l'un
d'eux pharmacien à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps ici la pharmacie
a presque entièrement brûlée pourtant
elle s'apprête déjà à reprendre du
service pour pallier les besoins des
habitants reportage de Lucas Chopin et
Sarago
Christophe pharmacien victime des
émeutes est encore sous le choc son
activité a violemment cessé il y a un
mois et demi un groupe entre 20 et 40
personnes
dégradées entre l'Amérique puis venu
jusqu'ici pour
entrer dans la pharmacie dans l'urgence
Christophe a fait le choix d'investir de
nouveaux locaux pour rouvrir rapidement
la pharmacie une façon pour lui d'être
toujours présent pour ses patients mais
aussi d'aller de l'avant ça nous a
permis de d'avoir une activité pour
avancer en fait on a eu des congés aussi
on n'a pas aussi changé nos habitudes on
a vraiment on a fait en sorte de que ce
cet événement n'est pas trop d'impact et
que c'est pas ça qui va nous empêcher de
vivre de travailler
les travaux devraient coûter plus de
200.000 euros prise en charge par les
assurances ici tout a été détruit
excepté un objet désormais symbolique
pour Christophe c'est notre cheval à
bascule malheureusement c'est un peu la
seule chose qu'on a pu sauver mais ça va
être un symbole assez fort qui va
pouvoir reprendre sa place dans les
futurs locaux pour les pour les plus
grands plaisirs des enfants qui vont
revenir et aussi des anciens enfants qui
ont qui l'ont connu avant la pharmacie
temporaire ouvrira la semaine prochaine
à deux pas de l'ancienne avant
l'inauguration des nouveaux locaux
prévus en octobre prochain